or quelles sont vos revendications alesi
un par un mais castaldi ah non moi tout
va bien je suis très content mais on va
très bien notamment nos choix je suis
très très content d'avoir des fois je
suis un peu en paradant mais sinon je
suis très très très con qui paraît que
vous avez passé l'été on part à nous moi
je dis tout ici jean macé où la parano
oui j'ai passé l'été à
pau gasol
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mauvais été où c'est vrai c'est
vrai parce que meiway encore disent tous
pourquoi j'ai passé un bel été ah oui ma
retraite parce qu'avant on avait plus de
garanties et cyril parce qu'il a une
table qui est s'est agrandie vous voulez
plus de prisonnier du nom de pas de
passage par codic on va pas se mentir
donc moi j'en ai avec 4 l'année dernière
-4 4 passages on est bon on n'est pas
inquiet on sait comment faire 4 donc
200 fait plus que nous non mais bien sûr
mais j'en fais je pourrais n'en faire
que deux oui et là ce serait un problème
c'est à cause de l'argent vous croyez
que vous êtes sur les chais la drh la
question vaut d'être posée pas la
question seront donc là vous êtes
content j'ai ça va ça m'a pas ouf ça va
supprimer un petit peu plus ce serait
bien quand même que l' accord il va
acheter quoi bein gérer plus je peux
rien
moi j'adore mon rythme moitié de la
semaine en province je fais mes projets
je circule un peu partout je voyage
moitié de la semaine à paris ici c'est
très très bien merci et bien pas moi
donc al seeb non moi moi tout me va très
bien même quand je ne fais pas je la
regarde c'est comme si j étais donc tout
heureux
moi c'est bien aller dans
[Rires]
la télé balawi dentelle toi tu n'es pas
chez valls allez
sur equidia on est très beau cdi blue
connaît
ce que c'est que ces conneries comme axa
avocat l'a appris cette semaine à la
bourse où
elle a entendu parler d'un truc de
saigner signer
un cdi à tf1 m'a retourné six
mois par ailleurs je n'ai jamais eu de
ces 10 du parc c'est normal de matinée
bah oui notre jolie bague ornée patron
est bien
mais je sais pas parce que ça c'est ni
vous m'emmerdez contrat à durée
indéterminée bats toi tu vas voir un
contrat
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est mourir sans déconner c'est
beau c'est horrible qui demande du temps
et de l'argent
a dit douter que ces gens me dégoûte les
normands sont les loyal et fidèle mais
que will smith fait de ne
pas nous emmerder pareillement n'ai pas
d'argent je sais ce que je vous demande
ça rigolait pas ce que vous voulez aller
sur toutes les chaînes mais pas par des
porcs oui mais preuve c'est qu'on nous
appelle pas
bah justement
des moteurs
a compliqué les bordels bo va très bien
alors oui vous à moi plusieurs peluches
est content mais sinon je suis mobilisé
tout va bien très bien lu moody's et
vous
vous avez déjà fait un cv
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais figurez-vous que mais c'est déjà je
peux vous réponds oui ce que voulait
dire quoi là mais parce qu'il ya des
gens ils ont jamais eu besoin de faire
un cv moi je fus de série et ben voilà
j'en étais sûr
c'est un gros scoop et moi sommes que
c'est une chance ah oui ah oui vous
inquiet sinon
voilà oui mais moi je suis commencer en
bas puissant mais bon là je laisse pas
tuerie best buy imprimés
[Applaudissements]
ces mots toi que tu réagis sur une bonne
bonne moyenne
surréagi
revendications ah oui sur le débat alors
pas d'argent rien chez marié mais sur le
b pile a souscrit une assurance des
maçons leçon
sur le débat bfm mac ça j'aimerais bien
dire au moins deux phrases d'accord mais
une phrase mal est ce qu'on aura jean
luc mélenchon qui va réagir pour luc
mélenchon à réagir au débat d'hier soir
ce sera tout alors oui c'est fort oui
c'est fort basse et fort oui c'est assez
dur et nous narre il s'est fort oui quel
est votre revendication je n'ai aucune
revendication j'ai beaucoup aimé faire
le 6 à 7 cette semaine j'avoue d'argent
si ça c'est pas permanente
mais j'assume prochaine c'est valérie
c'est valérie menacer d'aller là bas je
perds encore un tour la halle s'est dit
sûr qu'il va diriger vers nous et je
peux vous poser une question pour [ __ ]
un peu la merde oui bien sûr qui fait
les meilleures audiences entre montiel
et car ils se prévalent oui c'est moi le
meilleur l'autre et ruelles et les
lancent elles sont similaires là on va
pas se mentir voilà après faut pas
oublier comme que je vais quand même 25
minutes du 6 à 7 donc c'est surtout une
équipe
donc en fait vous dire c'est pas eux
c'est un accroc l'audience d'accord mais
surtout vous qu'est ce qui se passe dans
le 6 à 7 c'est la présentation des
chroniqueurs et qu'est-ce qui cartonne
c'est pas castaldi s'est pas montrée
elle s'épanouira c'est l'équipe
l'achat d'un seul n'est rien si elle
seule n'est rien hanouna seul n'est rien
hanouna montiel castaldi et toute
l'équipe ça c'est fort
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ceci pour la bonne bouche très c'est toi
si seulement
avec cette règle de banques qui font le
pull stif et le mois franchement je vous
dire je ne les regarde mais
c'est là qu'on va vous et faire c'est
pour faire la politique